former football player star Brandon
Marshall he played 13 seasons in the NFL
including six Pro Bowl appearances in
2011 a few years into his career he was
diagnosed with borderline personality
disorder after receiving inpatient
mental health treatment he's been open
about his experience and in 2018 he
launched House of athlete which is
dedicated to improving both the physical
and mental Fitness for athletes today
Brandon good morning how you doing man
good morning teammate how you doing
what's up baby one I want to say I'm
proud of you I love what you're doing
incredible work in your post career
stage thank you um let's start with the
diagnosis
what was it and when did it happen and
how did you respond yeah 2011 Nate I was
on a practice field and I dropped four
balls uh and that's the first time I
realized that something was going on
which is which is interesting because
four years before or four years leading
up to those four drop balls in practice
life was a living hell and it wasn't the
things that were happening off the field
that was getting my attention it was
actually the things that was on the
field that was getting my attention like
football's our Sanctuary right that's
our escape and that's when I realized I
needed help and I was diagnosed with
borderline personality disorder the best
way to describe it as emotional disorder
and I spent three months at McLean
Hospital an outpatient program going
through dialectical behavior therapy
self-assessment mentalization cognitive
behavior therapy and I was there from
nine to five Monday through Friday what
was the response from your teammates
even your family and friends uh never
forget we had uh coach Nolan uh
defensive coordinator legendary
defensive coordinator I'm sitting there
at the 50-yard line right after I I
shared with the world what I was dealing
with and I was doing this a form of a
practice called gazing and defense was
up and I was just focused on the 50
across the field and he walked up to me
said Brandon and he looked at me like
just weird he said are you on medicine
are you taking medicine I said no I said
I'm just practicing on my concentration
and so people just looked at me with a
lot of curiosity they were paying
attention to every move some called you
crazy some well everybody called me that
right because no at the time nobody was
doing that right and I'm kind of like
getting Goosebumps looking at this set
right now because Walking The Halls of
Congress and doing all the work that we
did back in the day the thing I used to
always say is we have to paint the world
lime green no one even knew what lime
green meant in 2011 2012 2013. the NFL
fined me for wearing cleats lime green
cleats to raise awareness in 2013 in
Chicago so to see this is amazing now
you you touched on it a little bit but
borderline personality disorder for
those who don't know what it's like in
the day of someone that might be dealing
with that break it down emotional
disorder Ricky Williams legendary
running back I came in one day I said
you think I got a problem you think
something's wrong he said Brandon no you
know Ricky's voice said Brandon no I
don't think that Uh something's wrong
with you I just think you say the things
that we all want to say and shouldn't
say right and I'll probably still get
that a little bit but it was that being
able to navigate through any stress any
emotions self-regulate get yourself back
down the Baseline right like that's what
dialectical behavior therapy helped me
do get those skills and tools
mentalization therapy be able to sit
back and process so McLean Hospital
helped me out a lot Dr Gunderson and you
know I always say I went from a patient
to provider there's so many reasons why
these stigmas exist it could be societal
they're also generational for a lot of
African-American men as boys these
aren't things we talk about we don't sit
down at the dinner table and go around
and look at each other and say how was
your day how are you feeling do you want
to open up to me about something we may
do that now as parents but what was it
like growing up for you yeah so so you
you know we're we're trained and raised
to survive not necessarily thrive in a
lot of our neighborhoods right because
of the things that we have to deal with
outside the home the conversations that
we have with our children our parents
have with us before we leave the house
so you always have to be tough you
always have to be on men football
players we're we're trained to be macho
and we're trained to mass pain we can
never show any signs of weakness you
know this even in the locker room right
if I say that I'm hurt then I'm weak um
we have a little bit of time I want to
go off script John Moran yep is in the
headlines and there's two professional
athletes who've been there done that
made our fair share of mistakes
um give me your thoughts on what you see
he is going through yeah well I would I
would say we'll be playing into the
stigma if we want to self-diagnose him
if we want to diagnose him but I will
say because of our experience and being
around so many different young men in
that locker room growing coming in as
boys ourself and leaving as men I would
say that it's immaturity right he's 23
he's young and and he's glorifying a
lifestyle that he doesn't come from I
agree with you 100 I feel like we want
to get away from certain Lifestyles once
we start making money but at the same
time when we get money in praise and
people look up to us we can create any
identity that we want that's right it's
not necessarily about the games that he
will be suspended I don't want his
career to be ruined because of this
moment
what I want him to do is recognize that
his life could be ruined if he's around
the wrong people that may carry guns and
are really about that life so for us
seeing the same thing this is a young
man who's trying to find himself that's
right and I'd say the sooner the better
for him and his friends and family it's
not necessarily about a circle it's
about him making the right decisions um
last question do you still want to play
football because Aaron Rodgers is
playing with the Jets right in front of
the teams I'm too old I'm too old
left for me I may have 30 plays left in
me at tight end give him a a third and
five Red Zone all right well listen I
appreciate you joining me and we don't
say this enough I love you man I love
you man all right good to see you
Brandon Marshall if you or someone is
seeking Mental Health Resources you can
call the National Alliance on Mental
Illness helpline at 1-800-950-6264